emily so good to see you uh
back in the mcu i mean
sharon's gone through a lot and what's
cool about this series they're allowing
the characters to really change what was
your take
on this take on her story
i mean also apologies for my dog barking
um
this is the new world we live in um
i was very excited to see this new
version of sharon and to
and to hear what they had in store for
her um when we initially spoke about
you know where she's been because for me
i didn't want to just like hop back in
and like things happened obviously
we haven't seen her in several years um
so
when we discuss this new take on sharon
and and
kind of uh this new edgy version of the
character um it made sense to me and it
was very exciting for me
to um to get to dive into that so
for her it's been many years since she's
seen sam and bucky but right away she's
kind of like
picking up after them yet again like
isn't she sick of these guys by now
yeah i think you get the sense of that
when we
um when we see her with the boys
initially that there's
that she's quite annoyed but also
they're kind of her ticket out
um and uh and as we see you know she's
been stuck
for a long time in this kind of world
hustling and
um doing her thing and so um
so she's sort of just tolerating at this
point i think
that makes sense one of the really fun
things about
these series is that you know fans get
to speculate on all sorts of things
do you pay attention at all to
everything that goes on on the internet
in terms of like where people think your
character is going who they think these
characters are
i mean i hear things i don't i i
didn't grow up with the comic book world
if that makes sense and so
i'm always amazed at how knowledgeable
some of these fans are
and i think it's amazing i don't really
have that so like
i'm amazed when people guess things and
you know have these different theories
um but in terms of keeping up not so
much i kind of just like focus on my
task at hand and you know it's such a
massive
universe to be a part of that um you
know
my pool of knowledge is very you know
sharon centric
just trying to keep up with that if that
makes sense
um but you know there's always tons of
theories and
ideas and thoughts out there and i think
that's what makes
these shows and movies exciting that's
awesome yeah we're we're all nerding out
over the shows and the movies of course
you said you didn't grow up with the
comics is there anything that you nerd
out over like are you a nerd for
something in
particular i'm a big fan of the zombie
genre
if that surprises you at all i've seen
probably every zombie movie ever made
um big kind of walking dead
um uh what else do i i love
like old 90s action movies weirdly
um probably perfect you know yeah i've
got my things
before we go really quick then
considering you're such a fan of zombie
movies what's
what is your top top zombie film of all
time is it new is it classic
how are we going here that's a tough one
the dawn of the dead remake was pretty
amazing um
but you know there's a whole thing
between fast-moving zombies and
slow-moving zombies and whether or not
say like 28 days later it's a zombie
movie or not which is one of my
favorites
but it's not technically a zombie movie
so anyway i could totally geek out on
you here
um but um
that's a tough one for me you're gonna
need a whole
i'm so glad we got to that today emily
thank you so much for the time
gracie